[Applause]
thank you very much please I know I love
you too but there's so much there's so
many important things going on but never
mind all that
Wharton Morning Joe is in her Twitter
feud with the Real Housewife of
Pennsylvania Avenue so let's get right
to that oh yeah at all you know it all
started yesterday when president what
the [ __ ]
poop tweeted another gem you got to get
them off the [ __ ] that's where the
Twitter I think it's the sitter in the
Twitter I think they're connected but
you know he's been seeing over the
criticism that he's been getting for
months from morning Joe and mica and you
know who he now calls low IQ crazy mica
and psycho Joe so he tweets you know if
they hate me so much then how come that
came to mar-a-lago around New Year's Eve
and insisted on joining me and then the
leader of the free world right she was
bleeding badly from a facelift that that
slapping sound you heard yesterday was
the entire country going
[Applause]
yes once again Donald Trump is
throughout this negative valuable lesson
he could never be too rich to be white
trash you know a little advice mr.
president a good rule to live by if
you're going to go after a woman's
appearance first make sure you're not a
fat old man with orange face paint
[Applause]
pretending to be a blonde at the age of
71 there's a blonde at 71 Mika
Brzezinski
you do crazy things to delay aging says
the man who glues dryer lint to his head
[Applause]
Oh Johnny you're so unattractive Melania
wouldn't even touch your hand and that's
a Twitter thing if I could make one
suggestion to see Bannon or Jared
whoever's doing the babysitting lately
get the president one of these you know
what these are the toy cellphones this
way he can tweet all night long nobody
will really see it and plus it's rated
for 18 months and up which means means
there are no small parts he can choke up
Clovis but to be fair to the president
he does have some traumatic memories
from plastic surgery one time he went in
for a weave reduction and the surgeon
accidentally implanted three chins so
that's and he also gave him a pool job
in the brain so that was good but but
that's not where the story ends now we
have yet another scandal which is that
White House aged are engaged aides are
engaged in what looks like extortion on
behalf of the president because joe
scarborough said today in response that
three people from the top levels of the
administration threatened him with a bad
story in the National Enquirer which I
pointed out last week is totally
controlled by Trump unless he apologized
to which Trump tweeted back psycho Joe
called me to stop Enquirer story I said
no thereby confirming he does control
the Enquirer
yep no wonder he can't focus on health
care he's editing the Enquirer today he
took a ran off the axis of evil and put
them on best in mort's beach bodies you
know which is all great for comedy but
you know the business of ruining America
goes on the Republicans all condemned
the tweets but they still vote with him
his stupid wall they're starting to
build that his stupid travel ban went
into effect as of last night people from
the Sudan Syria Libya Somalia Yemen and
Iran can forget about that dream
vacation of Dollywood and yet Saudi
Arabians on the other hand are free to
board any plan and fly into a building
of their choice but yes Donald Trump
says he will not have foreign nationals
coming here and killing innocent
Americans that's what the health care
plan is born
[Music]
oh yes there's that one too revealing
repealing Obamacare I mean the Democrats
are all excited that this is stalled now
in the Senate except it's not dead it's
like the slasher movie with a babysitter
thing she's killed the serial killer but
we can see he's getting up behind her
these are Republicans and now they're
talking I love this they're talking
about forget the replaced part let's
just repeal first so people have nothing
stead a big meeting this week with Trump
and all the Republican senators one of
the senators came out and said I didn't
think that Donald Trump had a grasp on
some of the basic elements of health
care for instance he thought Medicaid
was a sports drink basic breath and if
all that doesn't scare you this week
going into the 4th of July happy fourth
of July everybody is it too late to have
England take us back ok
but next week he's meeting with Putin
with the big day will he get a rose well
it's supposed to be a very short meeting
just long enough word for Trump to say
Geppetto am i a real president